[Música]
muy buenas noches con todos y la verdad
es que estoy súper contenta de estar
aquí quiero agradecer a todos los
organizadores de este ex pérez y
compartir con extraordinarios panelistas
y realmente no me había dado cuenta
hasta que hablaba con cristina de que
hoy es viernes negro o sea es black
friday quincena y después de que juan
jose a las siete y pico casi ocho de la
noche nos habla de las costillas berbick
y voy no sé qué que estemos aquí es
porque creemos en un green friday que
son los que me gusta ya van a ver porque
así que muchísimas gracias por estar
aquí mi nombre es bien cadáver soy mamá
de dos hijos de siete y dos años soy
esposa ingeniera agrónoma he estudiado
economía ecológica que muchas veces la
gente no sabe que le doy valor a los
recursos naturales
en emprendedoras es decir de todo un
poquito y el día de hoy hace mucho
sentido también con lo que juanjo decía
de su historia lo que llega un momento
de la vida y sobre todos nosotros que es
casi a los 17 18 años en que tenemos
esta gran pregunta y esta que vamos a
hacer el resto de la vida y es como que
si estuviésemos de este porte y tenemos
esta gran incógnita
y lo primero que mis papás no lo
hicieron pero lo primero que muchos
padres o el entorno es sacrificar qué es
lo que realmente quisiera hacer por él
me voy a poder mantener el dinero es
importante entonces por eso y algo les
voy a contar porque ahora último por
sobre todo estado muy en contacto con
gente joven que está más o menos en este
rango entre los 17 y 22 años y me dicen
blanca cómo supiste qué es lo que
querías estudiar y cómo supiste qué es
lo que quería hacer de tu vida después
de haber estudiado y a mí me da risa
porque la respuesta es gracias al
estiércol y el estiércol y yo si yo
estaba en un colegio donde había que
hacer muchísimo trabajo comunitario y en
sexto curso y después de estos tests que
te has - en mí porque tengo 37 nos
hacían en los colegios a mí lo que me
salió es tú puedes estudiar lo que
quieres entonces no me ayudó en absoluto
en este trabajo comunitario en esa época
había una comunidad que se llamaba la
comunidad de los hombres rata no sé si
algunos recuerdan porque eran hombres
que hurgaban en la basura y había una
persona extraordinaria que se había
graduado de una escuela de agricultura
de centroamérica y que quería ser
cambiarles la vida a estas personas
entonces necesitaba estudiantes para
hacer una granja autosostenible yo ni
siquiera podía pronunciar cuando
llegamos a este lugar me dice bueno a
mis amigos les decía bueno que están las
semillas usted vaya siempre acá mira hay
una es que usted vaya limpie mire usted
te atiende a los señores y explicarle lo
que va a hacer y me agarró y me dijo
bueno aquí está la pala de esos cerdos
que están ahí
deje el estiércol ahí abajo bueno te vas
a meter de los cerdos recoge el
estiércol lo vas a llevar esa caja
ahí están unas lombrices agarran las
lombrices con la mano mezcla las cosas y
ya esa va a ser tu tarea en los próximos
15 semanas
este hombre me tiene a mí me va a ser la
única que le hacen agarrar este cierto
y lo que las primeras semanas fue un
tema tedioso fue lo que marcó lo que yo
iba a ser el resto de mi vida porque el
ver ese cambio entre algo que es
considerado asqueroso desechable sin
mayor uso el convertirse en el entorno
correcto en abono que luego inclusive es
la base de lo que es nuestro alimento o
de generar vida puede entender que la
tierra es circular y que no hay basura
que la basura es un error de diseño
causada por el ser humano y es ahí donde
todo hizo clic
y dije bueno yo quiero estudiar
agricultura yo quiero estudiar la tierra
yo quiero saber qué pasa
tenía claro que no iba a estar en una
hacienda en una finca 24/7 pero yo
quería tener esa base porque entendiendo
la tierra puedes entender el mundo y
entonces tomé una decisión maravillosa
que fue estudiar en la universidad era
un espacio de cuatro años un sistema
super bien formado en donde la
agricultura no es el fin sino un medio
para entender muchas cosas como que por
ejemplo primero que
uno tiene uno vive en una burbuja
segundo que no existe una realidad
absoluta sino que es tu perspectiva de
la realidad
esto quiere decir que esto me ayudaba
muchísimo también hasta en mi vida
personal y profesional en donde cuando
tú quieres llegar a consensos tienes que
identificar intereses comunes y no
posturas que son las perspectivas de la
realidad me enseñó también que la
versatilidad de súper importante sobre
todo cuando quieres conectar con la
gente en que tú puedes estar apto para
hablar con el presidente de un país o de
un banco pero que también tienes que ser
suficientemente inteligente y conectar
con desde el conserje o el pequeño
productor en mi caso y que ambos pueden
y merecen el mismo respeto y que son
parte de una cadena importantísima
me hizo entender algo también super
importante que es la relevancia de los
conceptos los conceptos son muy
importantes cuando uno estudia y luego
lo vamos a aplicar en la vida personal
los conceptos son aquellos que permiten
entender el porqué y el para qué y no lo
literal lo de memoria y sobre todo y con
google no necesitamos memoria
pero sobre todo también me enseñó a ser
resiliente siendo minoría
lógicamente en mi casa habían muchas
mujeres que hombres entonces en mi
colegio habían más mujeres que hombres
también y en el mundo hay más mujeres
que antes pero por alguna razón las
mujeres son consideradas minorías y
estudiando agricultura
lógicamente en donde una de cada cuatro
personas es mujer
entonces me enseñó justamente a ver las
oportunidades en donde aparentemente
puedes estar en desventaja
entendí muy bien que cuando te sientas
en la mesa el profesionalismo
y la capacidad de generar valor no
depende de un género y que la sociedad
necesita de los dos
también me enseñó a trabajar en equipo
porque solo no lo podemos hacer y aquí
hay una lección importantísima que es
rodearse de las personas correctas
la verdad también me dio a muchas de las
familias que uno elige que se
convirtieron compañeros de trabajo que
se convirtieron en jefes y luego socios
y es así como desde el 2003 estuvo en
sambito que en ese entonces era un
emprendimiento era chiquito pero que
quería cambiar muchos paradigmas en
nuestra sociedad
primero que todo aquel que quisiera
trabajar en temas ambientales era hippie
y bueno si obviamente si es donde
partimos pero que tú podías también está
el vestido de saco corbata o pantalón y
quiere también salvar el planeta
que los temas ambientales no solamente
eran o tenían que ser cosas de
fundaciones o de voluntariado sino que
hay una economía atrás de salvar el
planeta
y es así como después de 15 años
aproximadamente después de más de 2.000
proyectos emprendidos de varios
reconocimientos debe de crear varias
plataformas ya sea de reflexión
ambiental o de educación ambiental
llegó la hora de internacionalizarse que
para una empresa es como guau voy a
salir y entonces por lo que ganamos ese
record guinness que fue por la
combinación del medio ambiente aplicando
el reciclaje para apoyar una iniciativa
que fracasó que es el yasuní
eso nos permitió llevar este mismo
proyecto a colombia y fue un proyecto
maravilloso hasta hoy recibimos este
mensaje de cariño recibimos un
reconocimiento de la cruz del comendador
por el aporte al desarrollo sostenible
la educación ambiental pero
económicamente fracasamos
perdimos mucha plata y la forma fue
difícil y ahí sale una frustración
frustración deseamos dónde está nosotros
dimos ese uno a la gente como uno la
gente que busca rentabilidad pero siendo
el bien y entonces ahí decidimos crear
los premios latino américa verde los
premios latino américa verde nace de una
de un sueño de generar una comunidad
latinoamericana que nos logre poner en
el mapa mundial como región porque
latinoamérica es muy bendecida y es
estratégica también para los grandes
retos que tiene el mundo y es así como
siete años después más de diez mil
proyectos han pasado y confiado en un
proyecto que nació aquí en guayaquil que
hoy aquí es la ciudad sede que ha
logrado tener alianzas de más de 200
organizaciones que una vez al año viene
gente de national geographic de y en fin
de muchas otras organizaciones de talla
mundial en donde el 70% de quienes pasan
y son parte de los 500 mejores venden
70% más gracias a esta comunidad y es
algo que a mí me llena de orgullo pero
por sobre todo porque me permitió
descubrirme y hacer clic también en
alguna frase que tiene mucho sentido y
es que uno florece cuando está en
comunidad y que al final lo que uno hace
es lo que uno cree entonces si alguno y
ustedes me están escuchando ahora y
siente que lo que está haciendo no es lo
que uno cree es hora de salir
es hora de enfocarse y de hacer lo que
uno cree y conectarse realmente con tu
propósito
yo les recomiendo de hecho de
conferencistas no este ex detecto simon
si yo lo leyó sus libros pero también
sus charlas y básicamente lo que él dice
es una teoría espectacular que los
invito a que lo prueben porque dice
identifica tú porque tú para qué y el
para qué es el centro porque el cómo y
el que escampe es variable pero el para
que su propósito es aquel que te
distingue por sobre todo y en este
proceso de auto conocerme yo entendí que
mi propósito de vida es ser una
catalizador a una conectora yo saco lo
mejor de mí cuando logró conectar
personas conectar organizaciones en
aquello que para mí es importante y lo
importante para mí es trabajar en un
mejor planeta que obviamente empieza
desde el entorno más pequeño como tu
ciudad
eso es lo que yo creo y en lo que
creo que soy buena
el cómo y el para que pueden ser
diferentes en ese entonces por sobre
todo premios latinoamérica verde luego
hemos creado un movimiento de sobre la
mesa un huerto muy pequeñito que es
crear una revolución sostenible de la
cocina donde juanjo también es parte
estamos recién comenzando y también una
asociación creciente ahí de gente que
cree es una forma distinta de hacer moda
y entre otras cosas conectar con el
propósito es supremamente importante
porque aparte cuando tú haces lo que te
gusta no hay horario si es que no es que
es verdad no hay horario si uno está
todo el tiempo pensando y qué más puedo
hacer y aquí más puedo sumar y el
balance es importante entre estas cuatro
es esas cinco cosas la familia en la
salud del trabajo la espiritualidad y
los amigos quien dice que tiene el
balance en su vida todo el tiempo modo
se miente
eso no existe o al menos por favor
presente en melo yo no lo logro sin
embargo entiendo que hay cinco factores
importantes y sobre todo el poder
demostrarle a mi familia que mi mejor
versión es cuando estoy auto realizada
también es muy importante en este camino
tener el corazón y los ojos abiertos
hacia oportunidades entender también
cuando es momento de ver que hay más
allá del horizonte y para mí eso llegó
este año después de 15 años de estar en
mi familias han visto y premios
latinoamérica verde que es una fundación
decidí aceptar un reto maravilloso que
hace que hoy yo esté vinculada de una
forma distinta a lo que ha sido mi
desarrollo profesional
y ese pico épico es la nueva empresa
pública de innovación emprendimiento y
competitividad de la ciudad si lo
pudiese describir en una sola frase es
el futuro de la ciudad es la cara del
futuro es el desarrollo y el motor
económico de nuestra ciudad en un
sistema de innovación que cree en el
emprendimiento y en el desarrollo
intensivo en tecnología en innovación y
en ciencia pero por sobre todo en
articular proyectos que se hagan de
forma compaginada entre el sector
público el sector privado la academia y
los ciudadanos
pero no he perdido mi esencia ni mi
propósito porque el rol es de conexión
somos conectores y catalizadores y he
logrado en estos 90 días de gestión lo
conformar un equipo maravilloso yo
coincido el equipo es importante que
esté alineado y que tenga esa visión
compartida
no hay profesión que te asegure llenarte
los bolsillos de dinero eso no existe
tampoco ese es el único camino del éxito
no voy a jugar que es bueno que es malo
lo que sí puedo decir es que es muy
importante que uno haga lo que lo que lo
haga vibrar lo que note no todo el
tiempo va a ser felicidad pero que al
final sientas que vale la pena los dejo
con una frase que a mí me gusta mucho
que dice abrace el cambio imagina lo que
podría ser desafía el status quo y el
único que no estoy de acuerdo con
charles es impulsa la destrucción
creativa yo creo que es mejor impulsar
la construcción creativa con propósito y
de forma colaborativa muchas gracias
[Aplausos]